we also have new be good to yourself
teas and new summertime colorways like
banana salmon and more
check them out and check out more
at
theovonstore.com
today's guest is a gentleman that i've
i've been uh enamored with for a while
i've been wanting to meet this cat and
just get to just see what he is and who
he is
i've always been a huge fan he's beloved
by many
he is a mixed martial artist uh he
competed in the ufc for a long haul
and he's currently fighting in
welterweight in the bare knuckle
fighting championships he's got a fight
coming up in august
and uh he joined us today right here on
the tour bus
so i'm grateful for his time mr platinum
mike perry
i'll sit and tell you my stories
thank you so much for coming man the
dogs man with the the the the bullies
from from uh
lazienne that's it
yeah we out here man thank you so much
bro i honestly i am so uh uh this is the
most excited i've been in a long time i
think man i really am i'm excited thank
you for coming man thank you for having
me bro it's a pleasure to meet you theo
uh crazy guy so
you know meeting a crazy guy yeah
yeah i think we're different kinds of
crazy huh
i don't know man i think you get down
bro
i think you've gotten drunk at a bar and
slapped somebody before
yeah i mean i have i definitely i've
bitten i've bitten people
oh that's a good one i won't bite nobody
really i don't want to catch that yeah
keep this up on you sorry oh i'm sorry
so you won't bite yeah i don't bite you
know
i'm even though i'm pretty sure i've had
other people's blood in my mouth
but like
you know we get tested to go to the
fight yeah so we're pretty clean
athletes at that time but like a random
on the outside no i can't be biting no i
don't want to catch rabies yeah oh they
had a lot of rabies busts growing up you
see somebody every now and then rolling
down the street bro licking they trying
to lick their elbows and [ __ ] and you
knew that they had been
you know what i'm saying they've been a
little too close to a raccoon yeah
they've got a little dicey man um man we
i used to have a couple raccoons that
lived in my house yeah yeah cause we at
my house in flint michigan
and uh you know that's pretty crazy
place up there and i had a big hole in
the side of the house and we had like a
blue tarp over it and we had aluminum
shingles on the side of the house
so
i think
my dad told me that someone stole him
but i think he took him
and then so then we had a big hole in
the house and we used to have raccoons
in there sometimes it was cool man yeah
he's hanging out bro i used to work at
this restaurant i was a boss boy over
there and i did other things too
i would sell a little bit of weed but
mostly i was doing dish work
but um
and when the chef would cook uh duck
when they would make duck they had loose
floorboards in the back of the
restaurant and they had a lot of
raccoons in the wall and one of us bus
boys would have to sit there with a
broomstick because the raccoons like the
duck smell
so they come out the wood bro and i'll
just sit there and just beat them back
in though yeah that's crazy so
definitely that was a five-star
restaurant over there
over there it was man it was but it
really really was yeah i said
that was a five star down here in
florida i seen something with the golden
corrals they put
they they had all the food on the trays
all the raw steak and golden corral you
can it's a it's an all you can eat spot
but like you go over to the chef and
he'll cook a steak for you and you can
keep going back and eat more steak
people like it
i haven't eaten there in years but they
used to keep the meat outside next to
the dumpsters
yeah they made like a video about that
oh yeah i stopped eating there that's a
storage issue
yeah right you know
freezer um
man i'm so glad i just i'm honestly i'm
excited uh
i'm not that fun though i'm not that
exciting i'm actually a really boring
like
you know
uh
solid
focused individual
you're you though you yeah you are you
you you couldn't be any more you i don't
think people love you bro thank you
people love grateful well i feel i feel
differently a little bit about yourself
there's a lot of hate oh really yeah
just
about myself as far as like what other
people seem to think or act or what they
say
um not that it matters but like
you know so
i'm 30 now i'm a little older so um
i'm trying to carry myself in in such a
way to be older to be wiser um i'm not
being a fighter is like i'm still young
mentally because like i i want to think
about having fun all the time
and then you gotta you know i i look in
the mirror and i realize or i see all
the stuff that people say and i'm like
you know on one side forget about that
but on the other side it's like you know
if they're right you got to take
constructive criticism and you got to
take a look in the mirror and just you
know i'm trying to be better i'm trying
to be an example
you know yeah
was there kind of a moment that changed
because you seem from an outsider's
perspective you know i've just always
been a fan and uh you seem
a little different over the past year
too you seem a little bit
uh
more
i don't know you seem i don't know if
it's more grown up i don't want to say
grown up because
that's not it i don't know what do you
feel differently over the past few years
and what's kind of changed for you as a
as a person well i met my girl
and um well i met her years ago actually
but like when i went back to her and we
started making a family together um
i noticed some things about her her
character that really just made me like
you know
respect her a lot like she's the
littlest cutest little thing but she's a
savage
and you can't get an emotion out of her
you can't get nothing out of her and i
saw that and i was like
these these grown men out here be acting
like little babies right compared to my
tiny little girl who then
you know these are the type of dudes
they'll cry
to somebody
but they're the same ones who would
bully someone that they can dominate
right so i try to be this person that
you know
for the ones who are weaker even though
i i like to do i like to think like a
winner i see what winners do i try to
follow winners see what they're doing
try to
you know
emulate that in my own way and
um but i still want to be that guy for
the weaker people
the people who can't stand up for
themselves the people shoot there was
somebody just about to get into a fight
in their cars there was arguing getting
in and out of the car arguing blocking
traffic for everybody trying to turn
right to come here
and like
i was like man i was wondering you know
if the guy is fighting a girl you know
what would happen what would i do but
right i just drove in the grass past
them you know and do you think a few
years ago you might have got out just to
see what was going on or no but you're
just right
right right
if it's not my business but if i do see
a guy fighting a girl
i would probably
you know help out yeah yeah at least
investigate yeah yeah you know
who was it they were talking about kevin
holland keeps saving people and then ben
askream wants to
say that he's paying people to do a
crime so that he can hunt him down
he's like how does this guy get in all
these troubles cause
you've never you know wanted any trouble
ben
he never did yeah ben looked like he
yeah ben doesn't look like the guy
that's had a lot of trouble really huh
no
i mean he's probably had more trouble
than me
um
when it comes to fighting whatever made
you want to fight if you think back in
your life like
were you did you just kind of at a
certain age start to see like damn i
fight or did it was there something
inside of you like is there a do you
know what it is are you able to get a
look at it whatever that is
my dad's a savage really he's crazy mofo
he's probably still the toughest dude
i've ever seen
and and you know he's just too
loose canon so i try to take that
and like focus it right into
the the art of you know being a martial
artist a fighter a boxer i really like
the boxing nowadays especially because
i'm doing it yeah yeah i've always
wanted to be a boxer i like the flash
the you know the outfits that they can
wear in the ring when when the ufc takes
everybody and they try to make them look
the same and then you know the grappling
breaks up the fight when boxing is all
about like
just
to me i i just have the word swagger in
my head when i think of boxing yeah you
just got to carry yourself with a
certain demeanor yeah and um my like i
said you know my dad was a crazy guy did
you see him fight growing up did he
fight
um
i heard stories we got in fights with
the neighborhood people
um i saw him make people back down from
fights a lot you know he would get in
people's face and be like i'll bite your
nose off
in their yard do you know what i'm
saying oh that's good i'm in your yard
[ __ ] what are you gonna do yeah
and uh you know
he told me
one time we fought like the whole block
and like i was trying to break it up and
i i was like 13 14 i was just getting
strong
and my dad i think he was drunk and he
wanted me to fight
with him with the neighborhood
and um i was trying to break it up and
he got mad at me
and then because he wanted you in it
right he wanted me to want to do it i
guess and like you know i was a kid
though but
uh
and i think he got arrested that night
and he
he got out the next day and he said that
the co he was talking trash to the cops
all night and that they drove into an
alley and they beat him with their night
sticks in the back seat they opened the
backseat start with his ass
it's good stories
it probably it probably stung a little
bit that's a good story yeah bro we grew
in my neighborhood people are always
fighting bro and it was a sign of
respect like everybody had their shirts
off all the time dudes walking around
with like those do you ever see the dude
with like the cement arms he just walked
he just like uh he the only way he know
how to move he just he never even could
lift his arms up they just swinging in
front of him we had that kind of dude we
had a guy who went down syndrome bro but
they wouldn't say he had it bro so he
was always out there [ __ ] people up
bro thinking he was in regular education
we had like uh
do we had like a whole family with
shirtless bro women all of them the
whole family was shirtless bro always
smoking in their in their house bro the
children were smoking cigarettes
everybody was out on the block back in
the day you know what i mean you had
your bicycle you drove to people's
houses you knock on their door yeah and
their their mama answered the door
damn where your son at
yeah yeah
yeah we got some [ __ ] to do let's go
dude that was so i missed that kind of
stuff i forget about that remember how
kind of crazy it was when you would go
to your buddy's house
because that determined your whole day
if your friend was home or not to
determine how the rest of your day was
going to go if you wasn't home you had
to go back to your [ __ ] house bro
that always it wasn't bad but it wasn't
the same as having your buddy you know a
couple places you know i had a couple
places to go i rode my bike miles every
day all over
and uh
remember i remember playing
tackle in the grass and two hand
touching the street football you ever
played that yeah and the car would come
and everybody have to shut it down bro
everybody call it car driving
brother dude's driving through brook
it's not even a gay dude it's just a
dude with his wife or something you like
this motherfucker's ruining our game bro
people yelling you queer just down the
street just you know just back in the
day this [ __ ] was fun bro sometimes
god it was fun dude times are better now
though yeah you know well your life's
different now you have more
yeah you know people say that joe rogan
always says that he's like you know
we're at the time where you have access
to whatever you want you know
well that's iffy you know yeah you can
go on google and look something up but
then like
there's so many scams out there right
where's the information coming from you
don't know what you always see i always
see that meme on instagram it's like
you know what you order online and it's
like it was like the good conor mcgregor
who knocked out
uh aldo in 13 seconds and then it's like
what you get it was like uh
you know him sitting on the floor
talking [ __ ] to dustin
yeah that's true yeah everything you get
now i feel like it comes from a
different place it's not that you know
it's it's interesting i think when a lot
of jobs left america for overseas when
they started making stuff in factories
in other countries
then the pride you lost a lot of pride
it used to be like your dad worked at a
factory or something so when that item
came off the press you had you wore you
my dad made this you know people would
tell that kind of story and now it's
like we just get it from somewhere we
don't know who makes it you know
somebody's dad is on damn percocet all
the time and you don't even know us you
know i think some of the pride is going
a little bit maybe but that could be me
romanticizing stuff americans are tough
with that though right like
like um
i mean
who do we got that the americans really
get behind as far as
you know everything leads back to the
fight game for me it's like conor
mcgregor's got the irish people they fly
out from ireland they go to vegas they
turn up they they come with thousands
and thousands and they blow up the
stadium
khabib
i mean
all the all the russian people i mean i
don't know how much they trap i mean
everybody knows the irish fans the
european fans i'm excited to go to
london uh shout out crypto face market
cypher real quick um i'm excited to go
to london last time i was there i had
that big fight with danny roberts and
that was a banger because i just i felt
the swagger in that fight you know
that's when you that was like your first
half of your ufc career right yeah you
fought two rounds second fight it was
your second fight so i was 9-0 with nine
knockouts after that one and we went to
the third round to the last minute and
then i got him and it was a banger the
whole time it was a good fight so i mean
i'm looking to
you know do that again
yeah what does that feel like so you
you're gonna be heading over there your
family's gonna go with you
yes actually so i'm flying to london
tomorrow
and then i'll i'll get there monday i
guess i'm traveling you know all night
tomorrow and uh for the presser and the
fights august 20th
and um i'm gonna my my son's gonna stay
here uh nine hour flight you know i'm
gonna bring my wife and
uh
we're gonna go she's probably gonna be
in the corner
uh
with my other coach my boxing coach and
um i think his wife might be going so
we're gonna get to see london i went
last time i saw manchester it was cool
to see um nothing like florida though
anywhere you go in the world i like
florida um you know and
but
you know shout out
england i think they're going to bring
the heat those fans are intense with
when it comes to fighting they really
show up over there you get stadiums with
60 to 90 000 people for the fights
sometimes yeah for like australia i
think they had like 90 000 people
and you know that's anything that isn't
florida is like uk to me right if it's
over there it's all uk australia it's uk
new zealand uk yeah yeah yeah
and then there's asia yeah
that's that's how i feel kind of yeah
sometimes i divide yeah to me like
somebody in the audience the other night
said their i don't know what ethnicity
they were but i didn't even know it you
know i said i know black and mexican
that's not in white
you know and i know it's kind of whites
are a little mexican yeah
whites are getting everybody's gonna be
beige bro in about two more generations
everybody's gonna be beige man good yeah
and then it's because then all the race
stuff will be going people can't even
you know they're gonna be like there's
gonna be something about a freckle or
yeah yeah
you know a limp you got a tan or don't
tan yeah yeah you can tell who stays
inside in the ac they got like a a
paleness yeah you know oh yeah you could
tell the sun makes me feel good man when
i get out in it bro i feel like god
wants me to be alive that's what i feel
like it's good for you for sure
i'm a little uh hungover today but
really what y'all do man i was just
playing video games last night uh play
this pirate game it's fun we sing people
[ __ ] and steal their loot what do you
what do you play it on xbox okay play
with people who are playing on pc and
stuff yeah i think they'd be cheating
yeah so we'd be winning i'd be like i'm
i'm here for it let's go
we sinking their [ __ ] stealing your
booty
i'm a pirate legend now that's real [ __ ]
i'm happy about it yeah i try to be a
pirate in real life too yeah yeah gang
bro
um
i know you got so i i know you moved in
oh i want to tell you i play metroid
dread on on nintendo switch
i gotta get the switch just so i can
play pokemon bro it's good you like
pokemon see i'm a grown-ass man but i
still want to play little kid video
games oh shame i need a break from
reality sometimes you know oh i hate
being an adult i hate being an adult
sometimes
yeah i mean i like being able to drink
alcohol and smoke and uh you know
and sleep in
don't let no you know even though my
wife's gonna yell at me i sleep in she
yells at me every day does she but we
have a good life yeah yeah are you uh
did you ever believe that you could be a
family man that you would have that kind
of life was that as something in your
head that you didn't think of or was
something you always wanted do you have
any thoughts on that
i remember a time that i didn't want a
kid um
and now that i have a kid i'm like i
remember that time because
but like i said i'm older i'm grown so i
don't need to be getting [ __ ] facing the
clubs all the time it's nice when you
when you have a family and you have to
you know maybe once month or once every
two months you get that opportunity and
then when you go out you only have a few
hours you got to get back to the baby so
those those few hours you're going a
hundred you know what i mean then back
in the day it was like you go and you're
like sipping shots he babysitting and
they're like
you know going half as hard now we go
hard and we barely make it home but
we're waking up the next day and we're
feeding his little ass and it's just
it's so much joy from just looking at
him yeah and i made him with someone
that i just really
i just love and respect
her beauty and her like
i'm telling you she's such a badass she
really is it's not like she really has
been an inspiration to you huh it's cute
for when she yells at me and stuff i'm
like it's fun to fight i think she likes
to fight with me too yeah it's funny you
know yes she is
she is the ultimate inspiration that's
her and my son you know and and
our partners are first our son my son is
amazing he's everything but he's gonna
be a little [ __ ] i already know yeah and
he's gonna have to do his thing and
figure his [ __ ] out in life
i'm gonna help him best i can but he
won't listen you can be right there
telling him look you spell your name
like this
he's not gonna [ __ ] do it you know
what i mean he's not gonna do it i can
try to guide him all i want but
ultimately he's gonna listen when i
when i
make him you know
see that i'm not really looking right
when i'm not looking he'll do his best
when i'm looking he's like
you want to raise hell he says little
sentences he'd be like who's this [ __ ]
who's this [ __ ]
he becomes a little bit like what the
[ __ ] is this
i'm like yeah
hell yeah bro oh nothing better than a
little kid that could [ __ ] curse bro
you know
better help get help for yourself if you
need it people need it and you could be
one of those people
god we all need help
you know i find myself going to therapy
twice a week right now and that's okay
that's what i need for myself
burn out is a big thing that's happened
especially in this world where we feel
like we constantly have to go
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions i've used better help and
i enjoy it
i've enjoyed working with them and the
experiences that i've had with them
it's more affordable than in-person
therapy you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours that's right
if your life's overwhelming if you find
yourself at night you're just gritting
your teeth and you're just chewing gum
at night even just you can't even you're
just
you gotta just you're on edge
if you're on edge better help
yes for me burnout was just like
uh god i just felt like i was always
just petting a really hard cat
and it was hurting my hand better help
online therapy reminds you to prioritize
yourself our listeners get 10 off their
first month at
betterhelp.com t-h-e-o that's
betterhelp.com
theo you know a lot of friends of mine
are going to domestic and international
travel this year
they're doing europe they're doing guam
you know people are doing all over one
fella going to prison and he's trying to
learn gang signs
babel is the language learning app
that sold more than 10 million
subscriptions
that's right thanks to babel's
addictively fun and easy bite-sized
language lessons
that's french
there's still time to learn a new
language before you head to your
destination
you only need 10 minutes to complete a
lesson
you can start having real-life
conversations in a new language in as
little as three weeks
with babel you choose from fourteen
different languages
including spanish french
italian and german
plus babel speech recognition technology
helps you improve improve
your pronunciation and accent
right now save up to 60 off your
subscription when you go to babble
b-a-b-b-e-l
dot com theo that's b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com
t-h-e-o for up to sixty percent off your
subscription babble language for life
i miss that [ __ ] but i just yeah it was
something about being young and uh i
don't know i always think about being
young i love that kind of stuff
keep you know keep the youth inside let
it let it breathe you know i guess i i
hear what you're saying with that
it's important but you also have to
mature it's everything in life is a line
isn't it you want to be the line you
don't want to be on either side of it
but
what did you start to think differently
was there something else that was so you
obviously you fell and you know you felt
you found your your
your girl you really admired her
was there anything else like when you
that help that kind of helped you get
over to that place because i find myself
sometimes still in a place of wanting to
be not wanting to grow up you know not
well it's gotta be hard being a comedian
because
you know
everyone
judges so much of
what is said and like you know me being
a fighter talking to
you
i've been you know with my girl i think
one thing about her is inspiring is that
she's quiet
and
um
to me i'm like
you know sometimes less
you know not saying anything at all is
the best answer but you you have to say
something yeah so
then you come up with these these things
that you say that just send people's
heads on a trip trying to figure out
what it is exactly you mean
if someone's paying attention that hard
but what you say is for people who are
just trying to enjoy themselves and
and not focus so much on all the bs
and um
you know it's
i guess my point is like you know it's
got to be hard because yeah i think
maybe you want to stay like in a place
where you could always joke around and i
guess that feels most like being a kid
right and when you were a kid you were
fearless oh man you just let anything go
say whatever the [ __ ] you wanted to say
and now i'm scrutinized for everything
so
but i still got to find a way to get my
message out there and say it in a way
that speaks it could be funny and
serious i think that's one thing people
like about me i'd be so serious and
they're like mike's so funny and i'm
like [ __ ] i was so serious i'm not
trying to be funny i think it's a mix i
think it's interesting about a lot of
fighters man i noticed was uh
i wish sometimes you got to see more
of fighters personalities some of the
guys i've gotten to know they have some
some of the guys have really good senses
of humor and people don't know it people
just see them as like these kind of
beasts or these like uh savages or these
creatures you know but sometimes some
really have the best person that have
the best senses of humor too you know
fighters i think we're really bipolar
think well i guess you'd almost have to
because i don't know how i could go from
a regular moment
to the moments i see you guys do
i guess i mean they
a lot of fighters i've met and hung out
with you know will be joking and
it's good time and then
in the blink of an eye
they just do like some i mean i feel
like people in general do this though
where they're really [ __ ] um
they throw shade or like out of nowhere
you're like what's that for they just
start throwing hate your way or like
negative comments or
uh they just switch and you see a smile
and you guys are laughing and having a
good time and then all of a sudden
they're like
like kanye west you know he goes from
smiling to him
he might be quad polar he might have
more poles
is that what buy is two i think buys two
yeah i could see him up in the ante bro
i could see him throwing three or five
six poles yeah
um
so man you got
your life's changed recently with your
work you are now doing bare knuckle
fighting and you've always been a
fighter bro it's it's watching you is
like
i could never fight you know sort of
watching you i mean you just it's almost
like you want all of the you want every
moment of the fight you know like you
what you just don't
you just
i mean you take the punch you just
[ __ ] right i mean it's like you were
riding in that that
i mean that's a dark [ __ ] like i've
been winning now yeah no i know i know
man a good mindset good place yeah with
the thought of winning and
trying to you know i don't think too
hard about trying to keep it going i
just do me right and i'll be ready to
fight when it's time to fight and what i
i just accepted my place in life i was
like
first of all how much longer are they
gonna let me do this [ __ ] second
i'm doing this [ __ ] so why not do this
[ __ ]
stop
trying to just
you know
[ __ ] the points
go for it i used to knock people out i
don't know what happened i'm a little
older but i feel like i would beat my
younger self wow but my younger self was
such a [ __ ] because he just i
used to just touch people and they just
[ __ ] loopy all over the place
now
i crack people and they're just like
keep coming at me i'm like all right
[ __ ] i don't know what to do
but just keep
doing it yeah just keep doing it hit him
and hit him some more if he's still
there hit him some more
you know that's what my career has kind
of taught me just give in and be all in
with what you got going
yeah it seems yeah that seems real
obvious man i mean you [ __ ]
i i watched uh
the last fight you had was it lane was
it the last fight you had yeah
and uh
and that was your first fight in in bare
knuckle do you it feels like from a
fan's perspective that that sport really
really fits you
do you in hindsight now having to be a
few months away from the fight because
it's legit as [ __ ] it's it's boxing it's
clean they let us wrestle a little bit
there's no need to slow the fight down
and go all the way to the ground
and
you know i mean that was lane's like 9th
or 10th bare knuckle fight
by my 9th or 10th bare knuckle fight my
knowledge of the sport you know what i
mean he taught me a couple of things but
i was still the better boxer and um and
it's just so
there's something about these naked
fists in a real fight against another
professional that lets you know
yeah you're gonna get if you get touched
you're gonna bleed and if you touch them
make sure they bleed and and you know
just keep drink keep putting it on them
you know what i'm saying that's my idea
with this [ __ ] it's real as [ __ ] and i
really enjoy that
aspect though yeah it seemed like it's
as real someone says it's as real as you
could get bro
i mean they got people out there i mean
that [ __ ] scene it just seemed like a
civil war you know some of it looks like
just something you'd see in a damn
horror flick yeah i feel like some of
the match-ups
i feel like people get lucky with
match-ups a lot i feel like i fight
pretty good people um and i'm a
[ __ ] too like you know i don't
see someone really
we haven't got the contracts necessarily
yet and we'll see who shows up i'll be
ready to fight in london on fight day
i'll be ready i was supposed to be ready
for a fight last night bear knuckle had
fights last night in hollywood florida
june 24th that was last night and
i was ready and uh you know i was
supposed to possibly be fighting other
people end up fighting because they used
me as a business token and they were
like let's do some big [ __ ]
and they love me over in england since
my danny roberts fight it'd be a
pleasure to go back and you know have
another crazy fight there and um
you know i just
stay ready for my opportunities to to
put these paws on [ __ ] yeah
yeah [ __ ] you dude i want to [ __ ]
punch somebody
you can punch me nah nah bruh i don't
know punch me bro it's cool bro
no stomach or in the face i mean the
face might i might bleed so no you could
do like a belly shot
i don't know if i could do you think i
could do i could do pretty probably
pretty good you
think him bro
it was good he pulled his punch a little
bit
bro that's crazy dawg
look at you smiling
this is a good shot man
you pulled the punch i don't know if i
pulled it or not man well i have dreams
the most famous person has ever punched
me really yeah for sure oh we could get
some i i dude i could i'm gonna text
some people then next time richard
fights i think i get jared leto to punch
you michael j white probably wants to
punch me really i feel like you're more
famous than him though but he's been in
a bunch of shitty netflix movies
uh michael j white michael j white
he uh he been in some i mean i remember
blood and bone was a good movie
he had good choreography for martial
arts but that's movie [ __ ]
and he um
you know me and him had a
i just got mad at him because i felt
like he was talking trash about kimbo
slice after kimbo passed away saying how
he was teaching kimbo this and how kimbo
was like so
anyways um
i just you know i cussed him out
and
then
i went too far
uh when you're dealing with these people
who got money
they're they're a big deal or an
opportunity and and you know
i [ __ ] things up like that in my past
but
you know and i kind of got mad at him
and you know i brought the real fight
out and talked some [ __ ] that maybe i
shouldn't have said or whatever but
you know so maybe if they have attorneys
calling we can make that michael j white
fight happen i'll fight him anytime he's
a heavyweight and he's a movie actor and
he he wanna act like and tell people
that he's a real fighter um you know i
fight any real fighter and i'm gonna
fight real fighters i know the movie
guys ain't gonna be there they ain't
gonna they ain't for it they don't want
the smoke
imma keep fighting i'm only 30. by the
time i'm 45
i would have the record and
uh
uh what's the word uh attributes or
whatever of mike
tyson cause i i just who gets down like
me i don't know anyone nobody gets down
like me yeah i mean i don't i
think nobody nobody i can think up
offhand
you know
oh jon jones
who else he's a savage do you know kimbo
did you know him no i never got to meet
him but i loved watching him on the
ultimate fighter and tough and
i got to meet rampage who
you know if you watch that when rampage
met kimbo rampage oh kimbo's on my team
rampage is just cool and fun bang this
chick i knew she was cool she's a nice
girl yeah
yeah that's pretty savage who was the
yeah i wonder who what ufc guy has had
the most prolific luck with women over
the years probably
me
well you got a beautiful wife you write
man so you won and uh you won i mean
they say gsp
oh really they say he's like a little
[ __ ] damn
i could see him being in there
just [ __ ]
he
you know i bet he's ate some nasty
crotches
i bet he probably eats it from behind
some people eat it from behind i feel
like if gsp eats crotch he he'd be like
like he tries to stay far away from like
i gotta keep my face out of that
yeah yeah yeah she'd be like do it yeah
she wants this great tough dude and he's
like ah
that's how gsp ease crush
bro you [ __ ] get a tour yeah
dude you're making me laugh thanks man
um
who else would be good so having i know
you just have a new experience in the
bare knuckle fighting in that group i
know that it's not new in your life but
is there another are there other ufc
guys that you always think like oh man
they don't realize they might really
really dig this [ __ ] over here
oh man
you know
i think
what's cool about it is that it keeps my
my grittiness
it makes you think more gritty it's like
if you're in a fight and someone pulls
out a gun you're involved in some real
[ __ ]
some street [ __ ] yeah ufc
the people who are in it they want to
think
and you have to believe that you're
special or you're high up
you're classy you want to become this
image of you know just all the popular
brands or
you know you want your sponsors
and you want the marketing and
everything to be so professional
and um
i want to take the sport of bare knuckle
boxing and make it that you know make it
more
professional pristine and like louis
vuitton
and uh
or burberry you know
um
i you know i don't know that's the thing
about it that's where it really does fit
me is because this shit's so real
you tell me someone that you think wants
this [ __ ] [ __ ] no no they don't want
this they want to keep their little four
ounce gloves on and their hands padded
and they want to not get cut so much
when they fight yeah you get the air
goes by in there but you're bleeding
yeah oh yeah that's a [ __ ] real donor
ship in there it's like an emergency
room like it looked like a halfway house
it looked like a halfway house at an
emergency room every one of them fights
it looked like a narcotics anonymous
meeting bro where people broke out
swords and [ __ ] that [ __ ] looked
dangerous man
yeah don't know who i respect those
[ __ ] guys oh unbelievable they look
like [ __ ] a lot of the time when they
get in there and fight sometimes you see
a little star glisten you see a little
shine from one of these
there
a lot of the fighters in there look like
you know drug addicts or like people who
just had hard [ __ ] in life yeah but they
got the balls to go in there and do it
and they're doing it for like
20
they're fighting for damn near nothing
you got to build up and obviously the
competition's not
as
solid as like someone who's getting paid
a lot more for it
so then you're in there with a dangerous
opponent but
you know
i respect all these [ __ ] different
types of people cut that i see because
i'm like man you real talk you got some
balls
um
shout out britain heart man she fought
last night she got the win
and i've seen this sport i've seen her
change in this sport before i entered
this sport i saw her she was such a
savage girl screaming at people
cussing them out saying mean things and
then i met her at my debut
and um
she was trying to be more professional
you know what i mean is it was cool to
see it's interesting you start to notice
that in other people that's interesting
huh it's interesting how if we kind of
are able to have some change in our life
in some way then we'll start seeing it
like in other people it's interesting
does she uh
do you think it's
as that sport is as
just the same for women as it is for men
the bare knuckle oh yeah i think the
some of them women get in there and they
[ __ ]
they uh they're savages you know what i
mean
they
and the women are pretty good at like
holding a tight fist
and um
you know throwing them sharp little
cutters out there
women still do what women still do
sometimes a smart fight doesn't matter
whether it's men or women people might
boo if you're doing what you're supposed
to do
if you're sticking and moving and you're
using the ring and people want you to
get a phone booth they've actually
got those fights now i've seen them
there was like people fighting in one of
those uk phone booths oh really yeah
damn there's a phone in there they took
the phone out
no it was i think
actually i don't know it it might not
have been but it was two guys in a small
ass phone booth bare knuckle boxing
they're in there just trying to punch
each other like crazy i was like i'm not
doing that
yeah i don't think he'd eat that man
that's where i might bite someone yeah
yeah that's where you can start
sharpening your teeth bruh um
what about um
whenever you were little brother y'all
ever do halloween and [ __ ] was it fun
did you miss it love halloween
last year me and
my girl and we dressed our baby up we
were three little devils yeah we were
all devils and
people were so angry
it was so funny because to me i'm like
you know the devil punishes bad people
right the devil is an angel right
why do you all hate the devil cause he
tries to get you you should hate
yourself yeah you're the piece of [ __ ]
that wants to do what the devil's
telling you you should do that's what i
think about that he's just trying to
trap you he wants you in jail so he can
put it in your butt
oh yeah the devil [ __ ]
he takes the back rose baby damn that's
what he wants do you think devil leave
me alone yeah
yeah i've had i don't know if i've ever
had real strong issues with the devil
when i was growing up they had some
people by us that did a lot of seance no
he don't go to louisiana oh well some of
his women did then they had some we had
some
we had some wild [ __ ] pass through
brother [ __ ] candlelight bad girls
bro feel like there's a good christian
community in louisiana though louisiana
is good it's sweating hot churches is
tough to
you know the devil can't can't go in the
hot chocolate it's too hot in there too
hot for him it's too hot for him he's
standing in
fire them hot churches it's an ace yeah
the devil now even the devil likes a
little bit of ac these days
um
what else do you see for yourself man
you seem like you're in such a good
place do you start to think uh like of
other things you want to do in your life
even outside of fighting
i like to sit home play video games and
eat
food out of my fridge and pantry you do
twitch and stuff like that
i don't uh i want to you should get it i
should do some twitch streaming of me
playing some dumbass game i mean this
pirate game is dope but
um
i just yeah i gotta set it up and
one thing about twitch i guess you have
to open like a donation box that's how
you make money on there it's like it's
donations
and to me i was like i don't i'm not
begging you know i'm not gonna be out
here begging yeah i guess yeah how do
you keep from making yourself feel like
a monkey yeah i don't like that [ __ ]
either you know yeah but at some point
you know
i'm gonna need to find
other articles of work and uh you know
take myself up but they keep coming to
you it seems like
it's almost like the world keeps
building whatever is next for mike perry
well a fight
is
in my ideas uh well i'm 30. i want to
fight till i'm 45 or even older i could
do this [ __ ] forever it could always be
a part of who i am but i don't know how
long they'll let me do it so now i try
to
it's about the pedestal
there are certain people who get in the
ufc they win one big fight and then they
take that and they make all this
business opportunity out of it me i've
always just been a fighter i've always
just my paycheck is just a fight check i
only get paid once or twice three times
a year max maybe and
that's tough
but i've been paid enough to where you
know but that money goes down every
month that you're not fighting with
bills and all that stuff so
i don't understand business i don't know
why i don't know how to do it and i
believe in my past i [ __ ] up
to where i'm trying to rebuild myself as
this new character
um not just a character but someone who
holds himself to a standard
because i've messed up in the past have
been the people that
people don't want to maybe
put themselves on with but i've also
you know like i said shout out marcus
cipher
they've
they've been following along with me but
there's no check like that fight check
15 minutes
max
and i just made money for the whole year
i don't have to do [ __ ] the rest of the
year i sleep in every day
i drink when i want to eat when i want
that's a pirate's life bro
it really is man
do you uh
i'm trying to think of what else i can
speak to you about man
um
what about you
you speak to me about you you got family
and stuff yeah i got a family my sister
going through a divorce right now and so
she's doing pretty good though no kids
but they got mold in their house right
now but no i don't have any kill i don't
have any kids my own but i want i want
some i would like to have a family you
know i think it's been hard sometimes
it's been hard for me to take that next
step like okay i mean you're a traveler
because work yeah they want you on the
road doing [ __ ] like that you know what
i mean that's got to be tough you want
to be home and you're miles away yeah
but even inside of myself it's been
tough sometimes to be like okay
if you you know you get married you have
a family everything's gonna be okay i
think i get so used to this world that i
can kind of operate in where i know how
things work when it's just me i think i
get scared sometimes that if i get
more people involved is it going to be
can i do it you know kind of i don't
know
right like it adds things like
oh i need to
fly to london tomorrow baby
like
she's like what
um yeah they just dropped it on me i
gotta go
and leave you guys for a few days but
it's for the best for the family i like
that [ __ ] because you know
you know who knows what anybody's doing
when you're not there
but it is what it is
life happens right yeah
yeah i think sometimes i gotta have i
think yeah some of my mentality needs to
be more like everything is gonna be cool
you know i think i get someone a little
bit paranoid like oh things aren't gonna
be okay you know or i don't or i just
get scared of change and stuff like that
you know um
but i'm working more towards it you know
i would like to have a family and i just
need to
just do it you know and i'll find a good
person i pray a lot about it and you
know i think that that kind of stuff
will happen for me amen yeah that's dope
man
i need you know i would like to have it
um
what else can we ask mike perry about
people love you bro people [ __ ] love
you what is it about you think bro
because you're you you're the only one
who could really know bro what do you
think it is man
um i mean
i'm a good-looking [ __ ]
and i'm savage
i'm in the fight game because
there's nowhere else for me to be
this it found me
it just i you know you asked me at the
beginning like how did i know or
whatever and i said you know my dad was
crazy and i remember watching bulldog
fights back when i was young i saw it on
the tv you know we had like six channels
the antenna
and i saw a bulldog and um
i was like oh that's cool and we always
play sports outside basketball football
all that stuff man
i wanted to be a
i don't know i guess if i didn't found
me i wanted to play any sport anything
football basketball
and then boxing
we used to do fight club after school
at school at the soccer field we would
walk out there and
bring gloves fight
after school were you good at it then
i was strong but like what is good at
fighting because if somebody else
everybody got a trick right they're like
oh i do this fake and then throw this
kick and then
you know i get knocked down but that's
always been my thing it's like you i'm
too tough
too strong
yeah you can hurt me yeah you can hit me
yeah you can knock me down i make
mistakes but like
i'm gonna wear you out
and then i'm gonna drown you
that's what it's about [ __ ]
damn that's crazy to know you can do
that
yeah how about that's interesting to
know you could do that bro cause if i
say that to somebody
they're not gonna believe that [ __ ]
that's a crazy
and that's fine but no but you don't you
don't say that [ __ ] he's so like as a
fighter
i'm like i'm always like damn what's a
normal person do
like what do they do
normal person like you a comedian that's
not even normal either
what is normal not a guy who works at
mcdonald's that's not normal
yeah that's not super normal i don't
know maybe somebody that just goes for a
touch on the keyboard or something that
goes for a walk
that seemed like a normal dude if i see
somebody going for a walk but also what
did they do do they type on a keyboard
for work for money
i don't know i had a friend who was a
peep in tom bro and so if you just and
here's the crazy part
and you know i met him at a certain type
of recovery meeting you know but
and i would see him in my neighborhood
all the time i didn't know for years i
would see him and then one time i was in
a meeting and
that dude said he was a flasher and a
peeping time and i was like damn bro
i've been seeing this dude the whole
time thinking he's a normal guy that's
going for a walk and he's out there
trying to [ __ ] show that bird you
know
and that's crazy and i remember one time
was at the liquor store with my uncle
and my dad had left me up there for a
couple months and uh
they had this lady came up she goes have
you seen my kitty it was in a liquor
store he was buying liquor
because he was a um
out-of-work musician
and so he's buying a bunch of liquor
and she goes if you see my kitty this
lady and i didn't know we're inside a
store you know in a building and she
just opens her jacket bruh she had all
tits and cooter
man belly and belly fat
i don't remember bro i was so horny at
the time brawl i saw was literally from
tits to couture i couldn't even see
nothing in between there
and that's that's being horny as a child
shipping is important getting things out
to people you know you want to get
somebody you want something somebody
left a hat or somebody left a uh
a big dish at your house casserole and
they want it back
you got to get it to them
especially if you have a business you
got to get things to people fast
time is precious when you're running a
business that's why ship station
e-commerce sellers like you
more time to do what they really love
that's right
ship station automates time
insensitive shipping processes so you
can get back to focusing on bigger
things
it works with all your storefronts
amazon ebay etsy and more everything
lets you automate all the manual work
that goes into shipping
if you're still doing the taking the
orders and you know if you have a small
amount maybe it doesn't matter but if
you're getting up to 10 12 30 orders
it's time to get help
get it automated get it easy
you can easily compare carriers rates
and delivery times it's easy to choose
you can do it all right from your phone
sign up using promo code theo for a free
60-day trial at
shipstation.com
start saving time with every shipment
that's two whole months of shipping made
quick and painless
and it's free to try just go to
shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the page then type in
t-h-e-o we've used it to ship out the
merch and
i've got the some upstairs on me right
now and um and it's worked well
we're grateful to them and we're
grateful to you shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the page and type in theo
god i remember how [ __ ] horny i was
bro i [ __ ] beat my dick right into a
damn fence oh wow
oh man
i would [ __ ] punch my dick i remember
sometimes it was so hard bro sorry i
just said it getting a little weird but
i remember yeah i remember punching my
[ __ ] dick into the video last year of
my girl
smacking me in the nuts as hard as she
could i was in like
i was on my back on the bed like
like a turtle
and i
was like dude i was recording as hard as
you can [ __ ]
smack that [ __ ]
that video had like half a million views
i deleted it though like a a month later
really why
i don't uh you delete stuff sometimes i
know yeah i delete a lot of [ __ ] dude i
do too people piss me off
i post [ __ ] and i'm like
like i'll post some fight stuff and now
i'm in this move where it's like no
you're gonna wait to see me
in action
i i got some sparring footage and stuff
that and i'm also not trying to like
post me
beating up people who are helping me out
either you know and sparring you know
you need a spar partner you can't
[ __ ] just always shadowbox and punch
the air yeah you didn't lose so
uh
so i stopped posting a lot of the stuff
you know fighters are like i want to i
want people to know that i'm capable of
like good fighting technique and can
knock people out and i'm swift and i'm i
got that swagger
but
when you post it
it might not be what you
you know it might not look how you want
that image to be
so and then you know people bring their
comments these [ __ ] who want to
talk [ __ ] about my fight and they never
fought nobody they fight that
they fight themselves out of bed every
morning because they're fat pieces of
[ __ ] or something yeah and
a lot of sick people out there but you
know
the comments mean anything no especially
you man the people your personality is i
mean
watching you fight is insane bro it's
literally it's like watching something
insane happen good okay
that's just from perspective it's just
you're like damn this is insane bruh but
also your personality people love you
bro so it's almost like i feel like you
they like to [ __ ] with me because i bite
it and i'm like oh no maybe that might
be one
bait right you're a [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] mike i'm like [ __ ] you bro
they're like oh i hope they say the
worst [ __ ]
say mean [ __ ] and then sometimes they
say something like oh that's you don't
[ __ ] move your head and they do this
and you're like okay [ __ ] you're you're
kind of right yeah
but like you're not right because
like the head moving your head comment
first of all
no one has taken the hits that i've
taken
obviously i'm moving some type of way
because i take them hits
but you know so
you just you type on that keyboard and
i'm gonna [ __ ] type on some ass out
here i'm gonna type on somebody's face
yeah with my fist baby a sdf baby did
you ever um
do you like taking the hits
yeah
sometimes i try to tell myself you know
don't like it too much it's not the idea
but sometimes i can bait people
to be in the right place like that movie
wanted you know and the guy's standing
in the eggs
yeah yeah he's standing on the x and
he's like oh [ __ ]
uh you right where i wanted you
come here you go come on with
it bait bait and switch
are there times when you know right when
you throw the punch that this game over
do you is there ever that does that ever
kind of happen or is it too fast
for a touch no yeah cause
all the best all the best knockouts i
feel like i've had
i feel like you don't feel them like
when i got ellen burger
i was just like moving
and i didn't even feel that on my elbow
um
a couple right hands i hit people with
didn't even feel it you know and
like that england fight danny roberts i
need him i hit him with the right hand
need him
just like trying to get him on the way
down
you never know you always try to uh
hit them till they stop you that's your
job you know is to fight until they
separate you it's not your job to stop
fighting because you're bit winning
yeah kill that [ __ ] that i mean
their blood contracts if someone dies no
one's in trouble
wow a lot of people don't die i guess
that's part of it if someone dies no
one's in trouble that's the thing about
me is right i'm tough enough you gonna
have to kill me
some maybe i'm gonna fight someone who's
maybe capable
maybe that's mvp maybe that's the
highlight of the fight right he's
capable he's knocked out some people in
some pretty severe ways i'm really
excited
to test that's my bone against his
that's a london fella yeah
mvp is a bellator guy
he yeah yeah he threw you know about him
he threw that pokeball at that dude
after he like
crushed his skull with his knee but he
don't got knees in this fight with me he
just got his hand
and he moves he's trying not to get hit
and things like that but
you know i keep thinking you know he
might not be the one that shows up
oh you think they might switch it out
we'll see you'll be there i'll be there
i'll be ready i don't care who it is
i'll be ready but
it is cool uh this fight
before the ufc days when i was like
seven and oh seven knockouts
it went through facebook it got pretty
big buzz we were trying to make the me
versus mvp fights
uh since back then
uh i'm a fan of mvp he's done some
really cool stuff but i feel like he's
always fought people
that were put there for him to do that
to them
and i'm not the one that you can just do
that to so we're both in for a fight
here i don't think he's the one i think
he'll be very hard for me to hit he's
very elusive he's like
that that thing at the car dealership
yeah yeah
yeah buy this car comes yeah yeah i'ma
catch his ass though damn
[ __ ] they hit the switch and the air
just come down
it's time for me to knock somebody out
it
and is about time man do you uh do can
you really is there really times you
where you are baiting people where you
were like okay i know i can get them to
hit me right here then they're gonna be
in a place where i can
yeah
i mean i just i feel like um
oh that's kind of one thing i thought
the other day about that moving the head
thing is like
why move your head if you could just
throw a punch
if you can hit them
instead of dodging them and then not
doing [ __ ]
just hit them
that's how i think you see people who
fight with their hands down
oh yeah oh
i'll be damned
michael van page is going to stand in
front of me with his hands down the
whole time
and i'm gonna [ __ ] throw punches at
him the whole time and make him put his
[ __ ] hands up i'm gonna hit him and
he's gonna have to put his hands up i
think it's so disrespectful when people
be there hands down and the other guy
just doesn't know how to enter right
because every time he comes in the dude
just throws something up and it it lands
it's got power the pocket shot that's
what they call that the pocket shot your
hands are down by your pockets and you
throw from the hip roy jones used to
knock a lot of people out like that
but i'll be damned and someone gonna
stand in front of me with their hands
down learn how to punch you gotta just
go for it
is there about you see maybe even
outside of your weight class do you have
any thoughts like uh of uh like are
there any ufc bouts that you wanted that
you didn't get kind of was there one
that kind of you kind of wish would have
happened
and it still could i mean who knows man
still could i get right
i'm a fighter you can i'm gonna fight
everyone's vision every cli everything i
will fight anything llc yeah you know me
versus mike tyson me versus jon jones me
versus jake paul me versus logan paul
floyd mayweather i'm trying to put
myself in a winning category it's no
disrespect obviously
me versus kamara usman i mean
and i think
you know that's the thing they wanna
they wanna you know ufc is pretty big
and uh it looks good when they're when
their champions win their championship
they got their nice looking belt they
changed the belt the belt used to be
kind of cooler but now it's cool too it
just looks like a power ranger thing now
i like the old belt honestly yeah
the fence and the bare knuckles and [ __ ]
or the brass knuckles or something and
um
all right that was like oh anyways
um
i don't
you know do i ever want to be so special
that i
i would look at the sport of bare
knuckle boxing
and
not give it its respect and say
i ain't doing that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] looks terrible i'm not doing
that i don't know
it it might look terrible a lot of times
but when it does look good or when you
see someone beat the f out of somebody
you're like that guy needs a challenge
right
there should be two monsters in there
really showing what real combat is like
bare knuckle punching in the face
and you can hold a little bit to try to
protect yourself
but mostly separate and box and it feels
grittier when you're when i'm watching
it man when i'm watching it and i first
even learned about it because of you
that's the first reason i even learned
about uh that my attention got drawn to
it and i was like damn that is [ __ ]
really real i'm looking to be quite
different next time from the first one i
mean julian lane was tough
um he was he was strong
excuse me i hit him with a lot of shots
and then my hands were busted and i
toned down the power a lot on the shots
and
the cleanliness but since that fight
since everything i've learned from my
first bare knuckle fight the the things
that you can learn only from doing it
you can't practice it who's gonna
bare-knuckle spar you
know a lot of people not a lot of kid
nobody and then you don't want to get
cut because barn training all that
you're both going to be cut and have to
go get stitches that's going to cost
thousands of dollars
so
you know
the
you can't practice it you can only learn
from jumping in the ring and
trying it out and doing it so once i did
that now i've been finding out more
about my knuckles about my punching
ability about how the shots should land
and are you training i've really been
yeah i've really been
focused on
you know
there's some there's some days i'll go
in the gym and i'll beat the bag up
bare knuckle sometimes i'll wrap the
wrists and beat em up bear knuckle and
then i get carried away and then i can't
use my hands for a week because i just
destroy i burn all the skin on them i
get these big nasty scabs and then my
bones get so hard that like i you know
what you can't even lift up a muffin
like yeah you know
i always be able to lift something up i
ain't never gonna complain trust me this
ain't complaints this is facts
you know you got ice and stuff like that
i gotta i gotta get a video somebody joe
rogan been doing in videos in the damn
ice bath
i'm about to get in there
and show
my toughness
i saw a couple people do ice bath videos
that's a good video yeah i i i just got
an ice bath not too long ago it's good
yeah but i don't know if anything will
[ __ ] cool you all bro i think you
just i think you run at your own
temperature dog
yeah try to be fiery you know i think
you do man i think i try to keep my cool
too though it's that line the fire and
ice
this you're in uh
almost in orlando you're in daytona
we're in daytona and orlando uh back in
the day they had
oh you know what i don't
know if those rides are still here they
used to have the dueling dragons ride oh
yeah it was carnival islands of
adventure
islands of adventure
universal studios this is big thing here
and uh i had you know passes and they
got the volcano bay
all the
um
volcano bays kind of fun as water slides
but the fire and ice they had the the
two dragons and these roller coasters
like intertwined and like they would
come at each other and it was good do
flips and [ __ ] it was crazy yeah
dude do you ever remember uh
do you ever remember um what subject you
were best at in school do you remember i
was just thinking how i can't um stay on
subject and how i keep changing the
subject all the time right but like in
class was there ever one subject you
were like oh this is the one i like or
this is the one i was really good at oh
man algebra man i was really good at
math
uh
you know i count this money and uh yeah
yeah yeah
you know i can tell the time really well
i but when i went to school i woke up
it's [ __ ] early
sometimes i wouldn't even go to sleep
and go to school
and uh
i would first thing i would do and i
wore a tank top every day basketball
shorts and a tank top i was the only kid
allowed to do it in school i think i was
i think he just did it yeah and they
just couldn't tell me no i just did it
they let me do what i want i guess like
yeah i used to go to school
i would
play i would gamble cards or dice in the
morning
five dollars lunch money i might leave
to 20 bucks that day or i might be
[ __ ] hungry that day i might lose
five bucks i'd lose to you just so
you're not walking around hungry i think
no no no man
we was all hungry kids we was all hungry
kids trying to take from the next yeah
and then you know worst case scenario
lunch time come around you steal
somebody's french fries or something
yeah and uh anyways i gamble in the
morning
and then i would go lift weights
and then i would go play basketball
those were my first two classes
weightlifting and then basketball
i was short stocky dude
it's about lunch damn and then it was
lunch it was weights
basketball lunch
and then
i was like sure it was school bro and
then it was like this is school and then
it was nap time bro yeah damn bro that
was school bro that might be juvenile
detention
i never
he's going to play sport or something
i knew i wanted to fight i remember my
first day in high school or something
maybe we had an english assignment
i was like ninth grade or something and
then
they were like what do you want to do
and i stood up and almost got into a
fight because i said i want to be a
fighter
and somebody's like get your ass back i
said who [ __ ] who gonna beat my ass you
ain't gonna do it
and they didn't bruh like that now
everybody know apk baby that's apopka
florida we out here we did it
we out here all my boys back at school
first girl baby
well look man best of luck over there in
london bro i know you don't need it but
are you just going for press right now
when you're coming back yeah but you
know
i fight at presses and stuff people try
me they can't be
they you know don't
i mean i'm bored
but you bringing me out here for i'm a
fighter and you're bringing me out to
talk we'll talk we'll see let's see if
mvp says some good jokes if he opens up
first or if he's just gonna be
respectful and like me i'm gonna have to
open this [ __ ] up you know
bring it i'm bringing the heat we might
fight at any given chance so be ready
i'll be ready
i'll [ __ ]
swing first and last that's the best way
to win a fight
i'm gonna hit them when they're not
looking
distract them
low blow
eye gouge
bites
hard [ __ ] tickle fast tickle
[ __ ]
tickles are good
surprise that [ __ ] and when they laugh
you [ __ ] hit him dog hit him in the
[ __ ] neck bro i'm gonna knock a word
out their they didn't know he's about to
say
uh baloney
[ __ ] surprising bro
mike perry man i'm a huge fan bro thank
you so much for coming and spending time
with me man it's nice to see you and
your family and uh
keep fighting bro it's fun to watch or
just keep doing whatever you want to do
bro i like watching you whatever you do
thank you so much uh theo it's a
pleasure to meet you brother yeah thanks
for letting me hit a ufc fighter too bro
sorry thanks for letting me hit a
[ __ ] fighter bro i appreciate it yeah
thank you
it's cool the ufc is attached to me like
that with people oh it always well i
mean you could do you you i don't it's
interesting about you it's like what
what else they gonna make that mike can
do
they keep making ultimately at the end
of the day right if it's you know some
there's a lot of people entertained by
fighting and i try to bring a good fight
um
i think you know mike tyson did a comedy
tour i think you guys are ballsy for
going out in front of a crowd just
talking well it's a different kind of
it's like you take these hits but it's
like when that when when you tell a joke
or you say something and they don't
there's not a response
there's that moment of like
right it's a different kind of pain bro
it's a different kind of [ __ ] pain
you know and then you want more of it
that's the interesting thing about
it i think even stripper uh strippers i
think are kind of like comedians
anyway somebody expresses themselves you
know
i'm doing them windmills on the pole
with your balls swinging for you your
legs too short right you can't have no
short legs stripper out there
yeah
i want my upper body huh
look i run man i got a good leg you look
great
i'm not look dude i didn't say [ __ ]
somebody else said that [ __ ] bro these
[ __ ] around here dawg this
neighborhood is going downhill
but i'm just saying bro you can't have a
short-legged stripper out there bro
stick with what you're doing man you're
doing great thank you for uh
entertaining the world man
thank you so much brother
now i'm just floating on the breeze and
i feel like these
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share this piece of mind i found i can
feel it
in my balls
but it's gonna take
a little time
for me to set that parking brake
and let myself all mine
i'll sit and tell you my stories
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load of
my
past
and these rails that i've been riding on
they want so thin that they're damn
they're
now